Kamala Harris has been in the news comma
Harris has proposed that schools stay
open you hear about this she proposed
that schools stay open three hours
longer to accommodate working parents
three she wants schools open three extra
hours but of course opposition groups
are already coming out against this plan
we have the leader of one of those
groups here tonight someone who's
totally opposed to the three-hour
extension of school a mr. Harold bottoms
thank you
I want to I want to thank you very much
for being here mr. bottoms call me here
okay mr. bottoms why do you oppose
senator Harris's proposal because it
sucks
I mean it's unconstitutional
okay well why is it unconstitutional
because we I mean children can't vote so
there's like no due process and stuff
okay well miss Harris is not forcing
kids to stay at school longer it's not
forcing them but if our parents know
they can leave us there longer they will
out shut up
mr. bottoms I'm confused if you don't
mind I have just a few more questions
okay Oh for the love of God are you
serious we're obviously just two kids
pretending to be a dinah dolt Oh Howie I
didn't realize wait a minute why is the
bottom kid also wearing a mustache
really that's the part that's hanging
you out okay listen we're gonna have to
call your parents let me get our
security guard Frank Frank can you
please escort these children out
no problem boss you two come with me to
ice cream Jail
[Laughter]
that's the way I'm gonna walk in like
eight years
[Laughter]